What the, what the heck, man? You're taking to me at caves. Also, is this, is Mercury Mine? The first thing I think when I hear Mercury Mine is like Bryce is trying to kill me with mercury poisoning because I know if you have too much tuna sushi, you die. That's what happens. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 132, recorded on May 31st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about the latest RustConf drama and our upcoming conferences. Before we hop into today's episode, I just wanted to give a quick
什么鬼，搞什么啊，老兄？你带我来山洞。还有，这是，这是汞矿吗？我一听到汞矿，脑子里想的第一件事就是，布莱斯是不是想用汞中毒来谋杀我，因为我知道如果你吃太多金枪鱼寿司，你就会死。事情就是这样。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 132 期，录制于 2023 年 5 月 31 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们谈论了最新的 RustConf 风波以及我们即将参加的会议。在我们进入今天的节目之前，我只想简单地
plug for a Kickstarter that's being run by a colleague of mine, Tom Palmer, who is more commonly known as Context Free, either on Twitter or on YouTube. He is running a Kickstarter for what he is calling the Programming Languages Festival, which is a new potential conference that's going to be held in February of next year. That's 2024. And it is going to be a two-day single track conference, most likely held in Phoenix, Arizona. And the Kickstarter has been running for, I think, a week or two. I meant to plug it earlier, but forgot. By the time this comes out, we'll be just under two weeks, so I believe a week and a half left on the Kickstarter. There are multiple ways you can pledge. There's like a $20 level, a $50,
宣传一下我的一位同事汤姆·帕尔默（Tom Palmer）正在运行的一个 Kickstarter 项目，他在 Twitter 或 YouTube 上更广为人知的名字是 Context Free。他正在为他所谓的“编程语言节”（Programming Languages Festival）筹集资金，这是一个潜在的新会议，计划于明年二月举办。也就是 2024 年。这将是一个为期两天的单轨会议，很可能会在亚利桑那州凤凰城举行。这个 Kickstarter 项目已经运行了，我想有一两周了吧。我本打算早点宣传的，但给忘了。等这期节目发布时，应该还剩不到两周，所以我想 Kickstarter 大概还剩一个半星期。你可以通过多种方式进行赞助。比如有 20 美元的档位，50 美元的档位，
a $100. But I would recommend if you're interested in going to this conference, pledge a full ticket pledge, which is $495. And obviously, this isn't going to go through unless if the Kickstarter succeeds, which I think it's at the 25% mark. But if enough people sign up for the full pledge, this, you know, might actually come into fruition, which is exciting, because I think this is going to be a conference similar to Strange Loop, which Strange Loop is ending this year. So I think Strange Loop 2023, which is a sort of ending this year. So I think StrangeLoop 2023, which is a sort of esoteric programming languages, functional programming-esque conference that's been going on for, I think, over a decade. This is going to be its final year. So hopefully this will be the start
100 美元的档位。但我建议，如果你有兴趣去参加这个会议，直接认捐一张全价票，也就是 495 美元。显然，除非 Kickstarter 成功，否则这笔钱是不会扣除的，我想目前已经达到了 25% 的目标。但如果有足够多的人认捐全价票，这个项目，你知道的，可能真的会实现，这让人很兴奋，因为我认为这将是一个类似于 Strange Loop 的会议，而 Strange Loop 今年就要结束了。所以我想 Strange Loop 2023，这是一个某种程度上可以说是结束了的会议。所以我想 Strange Loop 2023，这是一个关于某种深奥的编程语言、函数式编程风格的会议，已经举办了，我想有十多年了。这将是它的最后一年。所以希望这将是一个新的
of a new programming languages-focused conference. Just to highlight a few of the speakers, Andrew Kelly, the founder of the Zig language, is going to be speaking. I'm going to be speaking. Gabriela Gonzala, founder of the Dahl language. Jean-Huidh Manid, who's going to get mentioned in today's episode, he's going to be speaking. We've got Walter Bright, founder of the D language.
以编程语言为重点的会议的开始。简单介绍几位演讲者，Zig 语言的创始人安德鲁·凯利（Andrew Kelly）将发表演讲。我也会发表演讲。Dahl 语言的创始人加布里埃拉·冈萨拉（Gabriela Gonzala）。让-于格·马尼（Jean-Huidh Manid），他将在今天的节目中被提及，他也将发表演讲。我们还有 D 语言的创始人沃尔特·布赖特（Walter Bright）。
A bunch of other folks who I'm less familiar with, Sabree Blackmon, Oscar Spencer, Evan Ovadia, Don Wages. So people from all different corners of the programming language universe. If you're interested, top link in the description will be to the Kickstarter. Feel free to back this project if you're interested in seeing something like this come to life. I'm leaving for Europe in a month. I'm leaving for Europe for a month in about six hours, and now I've got to go get new glasses.
还有一堆其他我不太熟悉的人，萨布丽·布莱克蒙（Sabree Blackmon）、奥斯卡·斯宾塞（Oscar Spencer）、埃文·奥瓦迪亚（Evan Ovadia）、唐·瓦格斯（Don Wages）。所以，来自编程语言世界各个角落的人都有。如果你感兴趣，描述中的第一个链接就是 Kickstarter。如果你有兴趣看到这样的项目变为现实，欢迎支持这个项目。我一个月后要去欧洲。我大约在六个小时后就要去欧洲待一个月，现在我得去配副新眼镜。
That's just excellent. Are they going to be able to turn that around I mean Lenscrafters has a one hour guarantee and um I'm going to tell sunglasses I'm going to tell you the story of how I got this particular pair of sunglasses because I have not one but two
这真是太棒了。他们能搞定吗？我的意思是 LensCrafters 有一小时取镜保证，嗯……我要讲讲我是怎么买到这副特定的太阳镜的故事，因为我不仅有一副，而且有两副
pairs of prescription sunglasses just uh just wait though wait though you're on a limited time pairs of prescription sunglasses. Just wait, though. Wait, though. You're on a limited time budget here. I'm telling the damn story, man. And I am going to 10x this story. You're not going to 10x this story. It's a good start.
处方太阳镜，只要……呃，等一下，等一下，你这里时间有限。我要讲这个该死的故事，老兄。而且我要把这个故事的精彩程度放大十倍。你才不会把这个故事放大十倍呢。这算是个好的开始。
I 10x'd your last story. There was actually a couple people that said, hey, we're never going to find out who it was that disappeared, never to be heard of again. The year was 2019. And I was in Hawaii for the C++ committee meeting. And Hana and I went snorkeling. And I had forgotten to bring my sunglasses on this trip, which if you're in Hawaii is a pretty, pretty
我把你的上一个故事放大十倍了。实际上有几个人说，嘿，我们永远不会知道那个失踪的人是谁了，再也没有他的消息了。那是 2019 年。我当时在夏威夷参加 C++ 委员会会议。哈娜和我去浮潜。我忘了在这趟旅行中带太阳镜，如果你在夏威夷，忘带太阳镜可是一件相当、相当
bad thing to forget. Um, but we spent one day where we did a day trip to Honolulu. We flew to Honolulu for the day to visit my cousin. And so when we get to Honolulu, um, first thing we do, we get the rental car, we go to a LensCrafters and I tell them, how serious are you about your one hour guarantee? Because in three hours I got to be on a plane. And, uh, and they, they And they got it done in time. So LensCrafters it is.
糟糕的事情。嗯，但我们有一天去檀香山进行了一日游。我们飞到檀香山呆一天，去拜访我的表弟。所以当我们到达檀香山时，嗯，我们做的第一件事，就是租了辆车，去了一家 LensCrafters，我告诉他们，你们对你们的一小时取镜保证有多认真？因为三个小时后我得赶飞机。然后，呃，然后他们……然后他们按时完成了。所以就选 LensCrafters 了。
Can't 10X that. That was too quick of a story for you to 10X. That was short and sweet. That was short and sweet. I think the listener would be upset if they only heard your chipmunk voice for like five seconds and they'd be like, that must have been a short story. Why didn't he just let it air so you know what bryce we'll keep that one in just because it was short and sweet and it did have to do so it did took place at a
没法放大十倍。那个故事太短了，你没法放大十倍。那个故事短小精悍。那个故事短小精悍。我想听众如果只听到你那花栗鼠般的声音五秒钟会很不高兴的，他们会觉得，这一定是个很短的故事。你为什么不直接播出来，让大家知道呢？布莱斯，我们还是把那段保留下来吧，就因为它短小精悍，而且确实和……而且它发生在
c++ conference upcoming road trip that we're taking to slovenia you don't need to like sleep or eat right because i i don't really have time for you to sleep, Reed. We'll talk about maybe some technical stuff in this short recording here. But let's just say, folks, I'm a little bit introvert Connor. Baseline introvert Connor is a little bit concerned. Because let me actually open up our Twitter discussion. And first of all, Bryce is doing most of the planning. I'm totally fine with that. I'll do most of the driving.
C++ 会议上，还有我们即将去斯洛文尼亚的公路旅行。你不需要睡觉或吃东西对吧？因为我——我真的没有时间让你睡觉，里德。我们在这段短短的录音里可能会聊一些技术方面的事情。但这么说吧，各位，我是一个有点内向的康纳。基准内向的康纳有点担心。因为让我实际上打开我们的 Twitter 讨论。首先，布莱斯负责了大部分的计划。我完全没意见。我来负责大部分的开车。
We're a team. All right, here we go. This is on Saturday, a couple days ago. Are you okay? This is Bryce. Are you okay skipping lunch one day of the road trip? I respond, lol, what does skip lunch mean? I mean, it's pretty straightforward he replies there is a day where lunch is not in the schedule folks this is at 10 43 p.m on saturday
我们是一个团队。好吧，我们开始吧。这是在周六，几天前。你还好吗？这是布莱斯。公路旅行有一天不吃午饭，你介意吗？我回复说，哈哈，不吃午饭是什么意思？我的意思是，这挺直截了当的，他回复说，有一天午餐不在日程安排里，各位，这是在周六晚上 10 点 43 分。
this is the moment i discovered that there is an itinerary a schedule that is so detailed for weeks okay nobody nobody i i invite i create a tripet for every one of my trips and I invite everybody in my – like who's applicable to the trippet. And I still get questions every week or two. My mom is like, where are you going? What are you doing? I'm like, you're on it to the trippet. Literally my entire life is there for you to see. But she – the trip it literally my entire life is there for you to see but she so here's i've actually i have
这就是我发现原来有一个行程表、一个详细到以周为单位的日程表的时刻。好吧，没有人、没有人——我邀请、我为我的每一次旅行创建一个 TripIt 行程，我邀请我所有的——比如所有适用的人加入 TripIt。然后我每隔一两周还是会收到问题。我妈会问，你要去哪儿？你在做什么？我说，你在 TripIt 上啊。字面意思上，我整个人生都在那上面供你查看。但她——这个 TripIt 里面字面意思上我整个人生都在那上面供你查看，但她——所以这是我实际上我已经
looked at the trip it but the main page that when you click on it actually wait let i'm gonna pause that let's get back to the conversation and we'll finish this we'll finish this that's 10 43 he's saying that we gotta skip lunch i don't reply immediately four minutes minutes later, 10.47 p.m. This is Saturday night. Also, how much sleep do you need? To which I replied two minutes later, lol, what is going on? And I ask if there's room in the schedule for my runs because I'm already in Europe. I'm in Wroclaw, Poland right now. And this is how we operate. We go – yesterday we went for 17K run.
看过这个 TripIt 了，但主页，当你点击进去的时候，实际上，等一下，我要暂停一下，让我们回到对话中，我们会把这个讲完，我们会把这个讲完。那是 10 点 43 分，他说我们得不吃午饭，我没有立即回复。四分钟后，晚上 10 点 47 分。这是周六晚上。还有，你需要睡多久？对此，我在两分钟后回复说，哈哈，这是怎么回事？我问行程里有没有给我跑步留出时间，因为我已经在欧洲了。我现在在波兰弗罗茨瓦夫。这就是我们的运作方式。我们去——昨天我们去跑了 17 公里。
Today we went for 21K run. We see the city by running around, taking some photos, had a couple donuts this morning, both sprinkles. Absolutely amazing. We low-key. We here in Europe, we see in the sights by running. Who is we? I have no idea how this – Who is we in?
今天我们去跑了 21 公里。我们通过跑步游览这座城市，拍了一些照片，今天早上吃了几个甜甜圈，上面都有糖屑。绝对棒极了。我们低调地。我们在欧洲，通过跑步来观光。谁是“我们”？我不知道这——“我们”里到底有谁？
We is me, myself, and I. i refer to my it's the royal we and uh and and and you you will have that freedom except for one day of the road trip where you will not i just am confused on how there is like i haven't seen this itinerary yet but i don't know how it's so scheduled that uh we know that we're not going to be able to eat at certain periods like looking at the itinerary will explain the itinerary we had we yeah so i've been to that i've been to that trip at link and the main page just shows you thumbnails of the cities and i just assumed that if you click on that, that shows you your flight and your hotel and that's it. That was an assumption on my part. That's not how this works. We're going to now, dear listener, look at the trippet in Connors. We're not looking at the
“我们”就是我、我自己和我。我指的是我的——这是皇家“我们”，呃……而且，而且你——你将拥有这种自由，除了公路旅行的那一天，你将没有这种自由。我只是对怎么会这样感到困惑，我还没见过这个行程，但我不知道它是怎么安排得这么满的，以至于……我们知道我们在某些时间段是没法吃饭的——看看行程就会明白行程了。我们有，我们……是的，所以我去过那个 TripIt 链接，主页上只显示了城市的缩略图，我以为只要点击进去，就会显示你的航班和酒店，仅此而已。那是我的假设。事情可不是这样的。亲爱的听众，现在我们要在康纳的电脑上看看这个 TripIt。我们不看
trippet. We're not, we're not, actually we can look at the trippet, but we got to switch. Oh, while Bryce is opening this up, I assume he's going to share a screen because I'm not also opening it up because I'm here on my laptops. What are the topics, potential technical topics or non-technical topics for the day? Are we going to talk about the RustConf drama? I assume you know about that. You're not looking at all this? Yeah, yeah. We can maybe talk about that.
TripIt。我们不看，我们不看，实际上我们可以看 TripIt，但我们得切换一下。哦，趁布莱斯打开这个的机会，我猜他要共享屏幕，因为我也没打开它，因为我这儿用的是我的笔记本电脑。今天的话题是什么，潜在的技术话题或非技术话题？我们要聊聊 RustConf 的风波吗？我猜你知道这事。你没看所有这些吗？对，对。我们也许可以聊聊那个。
So here's you arriving. Then here's me arriving. Then there's the hotel. Then that's picking out the rental car. Then we leave here. Then we drive from here to here. Then we do stuff here. Then we drive from here to here.
所以这里是你到达。然后这里是我到达。然后是酒店。然后是挑选租来的车。然后我们从这里出发。然后我们从这里开车到这里。然后我们在这里做事情。然后我们从这里开车到这里。
Then we drive from here to here. Oh, my God. Then we arrive here. We have to here. Then we drive from here to here. Oh, my God. Then we arrive here. We have dinner here. Then that next day is the day that things get a little complicated. So, Bryce, do you know where you fall on the neurodiversity spectrum? Just have you taken any tests? I don't know.
然后我们从这里开车到这里。哦，天哪。然后我们到达这里。我们在这里吃晚饭。然后第二天事情就变得有点复杂了。所以，布莱斯，你知道你落在神经多样性谱系的哪个位置吗？你做过什么测试吗？我不知道。
We just – we don't know? I do not. We're both probably neurodiverse, you know, somehow. I just haven't taken any tests. But I've never – wow. This is – he's got it. He's got every single root plant. Yes.
我们只是——我们不知道？我没有。我们两个可能都属于神经多样性人群，你知道的，某种程度上。我只是没做过任何测试。但我从来没有——哇。这是——他搞定了。他把每一个路线规划都做好了。是的。
Hey, I gave you three options for the hotels for two nights that were carefully researched with lots of information just as I would give my girlfriend and you did something very similar to what she would do which is you were like too much information whatever I trust you make the decisions and so then I was like alright fine I'm just gonna do
嘿，我为这两晚的酒店给了你三个选项，这些选项都经过了仔细的研究，包含了大量信息，就像我会给我女朋友的那样，而你做的事情和她会做的事情非常相似，那就是你觉得：信息太多了，随便吧，我信任你，你做决定吧。然后我就想，好吧，那我就按我自己的意愿来做
whatever I want and Connor's gonna live with it and then later there is regret. If you don't want to have regret later, you should read up the, uh, you should follow what's going on. Because we have a
无论我想做什么，康纳就得接受。然后后来就开始后悔了。如果你以后不想后悔，你就应该阅读一下，呃，你应该关注一下到底发生了什么。因为我们那天有
very fixed schedule that day. Anyways, uh, our itinerary, I've basically just taken what our friend Gaspar has suggested and run with it. He is Slovenian. See, the problem on this day is that he suggested we do three things. And I looked at all of them and they're all pretty good.
一个非常固定的日程安排。不管怎样，呃，我们的行程，我基本上就是采用了我们的朋友加斯帕（Gaspar）建议的方案并直接执行了。他是斯洛文尼亚人。看，这一天的问题在于，他建议我们做三件事。我看了看这三件事，它们都挺不错的。
But the first thing, we really have to get there at 10 a.m. And then the second thing, we really got to get there at 10 a.m and then the second thing we really got to get there by 2 p.m and that really just doesn't give us a lot of a lot of leeway oh you're gonna need to bring some cold weather like bring bring like a jacket and some cold weather stuff because bro going in some case i'm already in europe oh i'm already in europe did you bring did you bring some cold weather things? No. Okay, well then you're going to be cold when we go to this cave in this mercury mine.
但第一件事，我们真的必须在早上 10 点赶到那里。然后第二件事，我们真的必须在早上 10 点赶到那里，然后第二件事我们真的必须在下午 2 点前赶到那里，这真的没有给我们留出太多的、太多的回旋余地。哦，你得带点防寒衣物，比如带件夹克和一些防寒的东西，因为老兄，我们要去一些洞穴——我已经身在欧洲了。哦，我已经在欧洲了。你带了、你带防寒的东西了吗？没有。好吧，那当我们去这个汞矿里的洞穴时，你会觉得冷的。
I'm kidding, of course. I have a spare sweater and jacket because I'm an experienced traveler. I just got new luggage. Oh my god, I'm so excited about my new luggage. It's amazing. All right. Happy for you. We're switching topics now to something that our listeners care about. Yeah.
我当然是开玩笑的。我有一件备用毛衣和夹克，因为我是个经验丰富的旅行者。我刚买了个新行李箱。哦天哪，我对我的新行李箱太兴奋了。太棒了。好吧。为你高兴。我们现在要把话题转到我们的听众关心的事情上。是的。
Let's talk about the rest conf thing. You've got thoughts. So give people a 10 second recap. My main thought is that if. We can't get your thoughts before you recap because there's some people that don't know what we're talking about so so rust conf uh invited gene heed um to uh to do a keynote and then um aka the phd on twitter in case you don't you don't know him by his name there were some internal politics and they decided that they were going to try to downgrade his keynote
我们来聊聊 RustConf 的事。你很有想法。那就给听众做一个 10 秒钟的回顾吧。我的主要想法是，如果……在我们回顾之前，我们不能先听听你的想法，因为有些人不知道我们在说什么，所以——所以 RustConf 邀请让-于格（Jean-Huid）来——来做一个主旨演讲，然后——也就是 Twitter 上的 @theprincess（注：原文 aka the phd），如果你不知道他的名字的话。有一些内部政治斗争，他们决定试图把他的主旨演讲降级
to a regular talk because they didn't like the content of his talk. And it went as predictably badly as you might imagine. I just got to say, if you're going to try to pull that shit, maybe don't try to pull that shit maybe don't try to pull it with Gene Heed um yeah is it Gene Heed or John Heed uh it's John Heed
为普通演讲，因为他们不喜欢他演讲的内容。事情的发展正如你所料的那样糟糕透顶。我只想说，如果你打算搞这种破事，也许不要试着去对让-于格搞这种破事。嗯，是让-于格（Jean-Huid）还是约翰·海德（John Heed）？是约翰·海德。
I thought it was John Heed I just uh I'm bad at pronouncing names but anyways he um he of course uh saw right through this and did the uh the only thing that I think a reasonable person could do, which is that he pulled out of the conference and he publicly posted about his experience there. And on top of that, JT, who they've been a guest on, CPP cast. Oh, I really don't care about the other Rust people here or what they've done.
我以为是约翰·海德。我只是——我不擅长发音名字。但不管怎样，他——他当然——一眼看穿了这一切，并做了——我认为一个理性的人唯一能做的事，那就是他退出了会议，并公开讲述了他在那里的经历。最重要的是，JT，他们曾作为嘉宾参加过 CPP cast。哦，我其实不在乎其他 Rust 方面的人或者他们做了什么。
All right. You heard it here first, folks. Well, I mean... Bryce doesn't care about the other Rust folks. That they did and controls should have been put in place long ago to prevent this sort of thing to happen. So my level of, my level, my level of caring about Rust organizers, um, uh, at the moment is very, very minimal because I'm
好吧，各位，你们在这里听到了。好吧，我的意思是……布莱斯不在乎其他 Rust 的人。他们所做的事情，以及早就应该建立控制机制来防止这种事情发生。所以我对 Rust 组织者的关心程度，呃——目前非常、非常低，因为我
fairly, fairly pissed about this. Um, me being a former conference organizer, this is, uh, uh, I feel his pain at this, and it's a really shitty thing to do. Yeah. And it's just a little bit unbelievable to me that they would try to pull this with him. I think it's unbelievable. As someone who has also been the program chair and been responsible for inviting keynotes, I don't see how you could even begin to think about like revoking a keynote invite.
相当、相当为此感到愤怒。呃，作为一个曾经的会议组织者，这——呃，我感同身受，这是一件非常糟糕的事情。是的。而且他们竟然试图对他说这种事，这简直让我有点难以置信。我觉得这太不可思议了。作为一个也曾担任过项目主席并负责邀请主旨演讲嘉宾的人，我怎么也想不通你怎么能开始考虑撤回主旨演讲的邀请。
Like it is maybe one thing if you couldn't think of all of your keynote speakers and someone who already submitted a talk, you asked them to promote if it was okay to promote their talk to a keynote, and then something happens. Like, I still think that is still completely, like, unacceptable. But, like, there'd be something, there'd be more of an argument to, like, oh, this person that we said that we made an invite to earlier could actually make it. But, like, if you're inviting someone who had no intention of going to your conference, modular, like, all of the context around John Hiedman Ede and, you know, his work on Rust and whatever, his experience with C++ and C, I just like, I don't even know how you get, like, they, like, I've read all this stuff and, you know, read all the blogs and the
这就像是，如果你想不出所有的主旨演讲嘉宾，而对于某个已经提交了演讲的人，你问他们提升他们的演讲为主旨演讲是否可以，然后发生了什么事情，这可能是一回事。比如，我仍然认为这完全是不可接受的。但是，这还算有点争论的余地，比如，哦，我们之前发出邀请的那个人实际上可以来了。但是，如果你邀请了一个本来完全不打算去你的会议的人——抛开所有关于约翰·海德曼（John Heeman Ede）及其在 Rust 等方面的工作、他对 C++ 和 C 的经验的背景不谈——我只是觉得——我甚至不知道你是怎么能——他们，比如——我读了所有这些东西，你知道的，读了所有的博客和
Twitters and whatnot. And I just am like, if I am the conference organizer or program chair, it is, I would just be like, no, you know how awkward that is to go to someone and be like, Hey, I know we really wanted you. And, uh, we've invited you and agreed to pay all your expenses, but, uh, we've changed our minds. Like, it's just so, I don't know. How do you even begin to think about doing that? Let alone actually execute on that? It just blows my mind. Well, it's – that's pretty shitty. I mean, you know, my – the general policy at the conferences that I've been involved in organizing with keynotes is you invite the person, not the topic, and you invite the person to keynote, and then they sort of get to talk about whatever they want to talk about that's sort of the point of the keynote you don't you don't get to have a
Twitter 之类的。然后我就想，如果我是会议组织者或程序委员会主席，我就会觉得，不，你知道去对一个人说“嘿，我知道我们真的很想让你来，而且我们已经邀请了你并同意支付你所有的费用，但是，呃，我们改变主意了”有多尴尬吗？这简直是……我不知道。你怎么会开始考虑做这种事？更不用说付诸行动了？这简直让我大开眼界。好吧，这——这真是太糟糕了。我的意思是，你知道，我参与组织过的会议关于主旨演讲的一般政策是，你邀请的是人，而不是主题，你邀请这个人来做主旨演讲，然后他们基本上可以谈论他们想谈论的任何事情——这才是主旨演讲的意义所在。你不能、你不能对它进行大量的编辑控制。所以——所以，是的，是的，我认为这就是——CPP North 的第一年，那正是我担任程序委员会主席的时候，我想。基本上所有四个。好吧，所以，我的意思是，我们显然邀请了来自谷歌的钱德勒（Chandler），我们知道他将做一个关于 Carbon 的演讲。但对于其他三个人，我们基本上邀请了他们，并告诉他们，你们可以自由地——除了提前几周外，我们甚至连他们大多数人的演讲标题都没有。我记得曾与程序委员会——或者不是程序委员会，而是与会议董事会的主席讨论过。他们说，我们是否应该索要演讲标题，以便我们可以早点开始宣传他们的演讲？
ton of editorial control over that so um so yeah yeah i think that is that's the with cpp north with the first year that was when i was c that was when i was program chair, I think. Basically, all four. Well, so, I mean, we invited Chandler, obviously, from Google, and we knew he was going to be giving a talk about Carbon. But for the other three, we basically invited them and said, you're free to, like, we didn't even have titles from most of them except for a couple weeks out. And I remember having discussions with the program committee or not the program committee with the chair of the, with the conference board. And they were saying, should we ask for titles so that we can start promoting their talks earlier?
我基本上就觉得，我理解这样做的原因。但答案是不行，因为他们中的很多人还没有定下来。他们还在考虑要讲什么。我不想把他们逼进一个必须在提前两个月就做决定的死胡同里。他们的名字应该足以给我们的会议带来轰动。如果我们能在提前三天拿到他们的演讲标题，那我们就那时候再发公告。因为理想情况下，你邀请的主旨演讲嘉宾是——你知道你邀请他们是有原因的，对吧？所以，如果你邀请肖恩（Sean）或凯特（Kate）或者其他任何人，我不管他们讲什么都觉得很高兴——无论如何我都会去听他们的演讲，对吧？这就是为什么他们是主旨演讲嘉宾。所以，是的，我的意思是，呃——Rust 社区需要把他们那一团糟的事情整理好。我的意思是，关于整个情况，有一件看起来相当有问题的事情是，Rust 这种临时的领导层结构已经持续了，我想有一年多了吧，因为之前的领导层结构在其中一部分人辞职后就崩溃了。是的。是的。所以，Rust 的人们，表现好一点吧。表现好一点吧。
And I basically was just like, I understand the reason for that. But the answer is no, because a lot of them haven't. They're still thinking about what they're going to talk about. And I don't want to force them into a box where they have to decide two months out. Their names should be enough to like bring buzz to our conference. And if we get their talk title like three days out, that's when we make the announcement. Because ideally, the keynote speakers that you're inviting are like you know you're inviting them for a reason right so like if you're inviting sean or kate or whoever it is like i'm happy with whatever
我不确定你是否也听说过，关于——我其实并不了解内幕，但有 Rust 基金会，然后因为某些模组团队辞职或核心团队辞职的风波，人们建立了 Rust 项目，所以现在他们有两股相互竞争的实体。除此之外，我不知道你是否听说过商标的事情。
they're talking about like i'm gonna go to their talk regardless right like that's why they're keynote speakers so yeah i mean uh the the um the rust community needs to get their shit together i mean one of the things that seemed quite problematic about this whole situation is that rust has sort of been in this has had this interim leadership structure for like i think more than a year now because the previous leadership structure blew up after some part of it resigned. Yeah. Yeah. So do better, Rust people. Do better.
是的，我确实听说过那个闹剧，比如你不能在域名甚至是在 cargo 或 crates.io 的包名中使用 rust。因为，你知道的，这复杂得多，网上有很多人们谈论这个的视频。
I'm not sure how much you've heard, too, about, like, I don't really know the ins and outs, but there's the Rust Foundation, and then because of the drama with some mod team resigning or core team resigning, people set up the Rust project, so now they have, like, two competing entities. And on top of that i'm not sure if you heard about the trademark yes i did hear about that fiasco where like they're you're not allowed to use rust in the name of like domains or even in package names on like cargo or crates.io and so because like you know it's it's a lot more, there's a bunch of videos online of people talking about it.
而且有很多来来回回的争论。我只关注了其中百分之 X 的内容。但正因为如此，外面的某些人 fork 了 Rust 仓库，他们把他们的新语言叫做 Crablang。我只是觉得这太滑稽了，一个前 20、可以说是前 20、甚至可以说很快成为世界前 10 的语言，竟然让他们的社区如此不安，或者说让与 Rust 相关的某些实体如此不安——因为显然有 Rust 语言，然后有基金会，现在还有 Rust 项目，所有这些东西并不是同一个东西。但由于这些领导层的人做出了一些让人不安的决定，而且据我所知，目前只有一个实现……
And there's been a lot of back and forth. I've only followed like, you know, X percent of it. But because of this, some folks out there forked the Rust repo and they're calling their new language Crablang. and i just think that's hilarious that like a top 20 top top 20 arguably like soon to be top 10 language in the world is upsetting their community so much or like certain entities associated with rust because obviously there's the rust language and then there's you know the foundation and now there's the rust project and all of these things are not one in the same but because of these leadership folks uh making certain decisions that are upsetting people, and from what I know, there's only one implementation of...
我的意思是，我猜 GCC 开始了，他们宣布将构建一个 Rust 编译器。但在那之前，真的只有一个实现。所以人们决定 fork 它。而且我，我猜这只会像是一个提醒，嘿，你们的社区很不满，表现好一点。一旦他们开始表现得更好，他们可能会放弃 Crablang。因为我从未听说过——我的意思是，有 Crystal，它是 Rust 的重新实现——或者说不是 Rust，而是旨在更像 C 的 Ruby。
I mean, I guess GCC started, they announced that they were going to be building a Rust compiler. But up until then, there's only really the one implementation. And so people have decided to fork it. And I mean, I don't, I would guess that this is just going to be kind of like a reminder that, hey, your community is upset, do better. And once they start to do better, they'll probably abandon Crab Lane. Cause I've never heard of, I mean, there's Crystal, which is a re-implementation of Rust or not Rust, Ruby to be more C-like.
我不确定那是不是一个 fork，但我从未听说过人们去 fork 一个开源语言，不是为了做什么天翻地覆的不同事情，而是——我想他们的描述字面意思就是“100% 的 Rust，0% 的领导层垃圾”之类的。是的。我的意思是，有些人需要辞职。我知道我听说有些人已经辞职了，但我的感觉是可能需要更多人辞职。好吧，所以我刚才提到的那个个体 JT，他是杰森·特纳（Jason Turner）的表弟、CPPcast 的前联合主持人，他们辞职并不是因为他们做了什么错事。他们辞职是因为他们对发生这一切感到非常沮丧。而且他们最初是提名让-于格担任主旨演讲嘉宾的两个人之一。然后他们在——
And I'm not sure if that was a fork, but I've never actually heard of people forking an open source language, not to do anything drastically different, but just, I think they're literally, their description is 100% Rust with 0% of the leadership garbage or something like that. Yeah. I mean, some people need to resign. I know I heard that some people have already resigned, but my sense is that more people probably need to resign. Well, so the individual I mentioned, JT, who is Jason Turner's cousin, former co-host of CPPcast, they resigned not because they did anything wrong. They resigned because they were so upset that this had happened. And they were originally one of the two people that nominated Jean-Huid to be a keynote speaker. And then they held some internal vote in the
我记不清是基金会还是项目组了，但某群人进行了投票，投票通过了。然后在那个时候到——你知道的，让-于格被邀请之间，其他一些人在没有任何投票的情况下决定推翻这个决定。所以 JT 气坏了，以至于我认为他们辞去了那个职务。而且我认为在他们发推文的几乎同时，他们持有的其他所有 Rust 职位也……我的倾向是，可能一些会议组织者也需要退一步，因为这里的问题与其说是这件事发生了，不如说这可能不是第一次发生。所以这种行为模式比其他任何事情都更让人担忧，
I can't remember if it was foundation or project, but some group of people voted and the vote passed. And then in between then and like, you know, Jean-Huid being invited, some other people without any vote decided to like reverse that. And so JT was so upset that I think they resigned from that role. And I think effective immediately when they posted their tweet, every other Rust role that they held because... I mean, my inclination here is that probably some of the conference organizers need to take a step back as well because the problem here isn't so much that this happened, it's that this probably isn't the first time that it happened. And so the pattern of behavior is more troubling than anything else,
这也是让-于格在他的文章中指出的，你知道，这并不是第一次发生。这只是第一次有人大声说出来。所以，是的，至少我从会议中得到的经验是，水面之下总是有更多的烂事在发生……所以可能该是时候换一换领导层了。总的来说，让人们在领导岗位上待太久不是个好主意，轮换总是好的。对于目前正在组织那个会议的某些人来说，这也是一个绝佳的机会，
which is something that I think Jane Heade points out in his, in his post, that, you know, this isn't the first time that it's happened. It's just the first time that somebody spoke up about it. And so that, yeah, at least my experience with conferences is that there's always more shit happening under the surface um and so it's probably time for some for some new for some new leadership there and that's just generally a good idea that you shouldn't have people in leadership for too long it's always good to rotate and this is an excellent opportunity for some some of the people who are currently organizing that conference um uh to to take a step back.
可以退居幕后。而且这并不像——就像我读到的那样，我读到一些关于某些会议组织者的事，他们非常抱歉，他们你知道的，曾受到这些其他 Rust 人、这些 Rust 领导层之人的压力，他们是非技术的，组织会议的人不是 Rust 领导层那样的人，他们的专业是会议组织，他们不是 Rust 的贡献者，他们与 Rust 的许多技术和政治方面保持着一定的距离，但即便如此，
And it doesn't like, like, like I read, I read some things with some of the conference organizers where they, they were very apologetic. They, you know, they'd sort of been pressured by the, these other Rust peop, these Rust leadership people and that they're non-technical, that the people who are organized the conference are conference are not like the Rust leadership people, that their expertise is conference organizing and that they're not like Rust contributors and that they're sort of removed from a lot of like the Rust technical and political aspects. aspects, but, but even so, um, they probably need to resign because they, um, uh, they, they enabled this to happen. Um, they've probably enabled other things to happen in the past. Um, they may not even realize exactly what they've enabled to happen in the past, but,
他们可能还是需要辞职，因为他们——他们纵容了这一切的发生。他们过去可能还纵容了其他事情的发生。他们甚至可能没有意识到自己过去到底纵容了什么事情的发生，但是，
um, this is, uh, this is indication of, of, uh, deeper rot under the surface. And when you have black mold in your apartment, you just got to tear everything down and completely refurbish it. So this can be an opportunity for RustConf and the Rust language to do better. But that will require some new leadership. Yep. People can come check out Circle too. Yes. If you don't like Rust and you're scared of C++.
这表明了水面之下更深层次的腐烂。当你公寓里有黑霉菌时，你只能把一切都拆掉并彻底翻新。所以这可以成为 RustConf 和 Rust 语言做得更好的契机。但这需要一些新的领导层。是的。人们也可以去看看 Circle。是的。如果你不喜欢 Rust 并且害怕 C++。
But Circle is C++. I mean, that's your motto. It's Sean's motto. I'm just accurately conveying it. I mean, Circle's, you know, like we said, it's the Charmander. Or no, Charizard. It's the Charizard of C's the Charmander. Or no, Charizard. It's the Charizard of C++ of Charmander.
但 Circle 就是 C++。我的意思是，那是你的座右铭。那是肖恩的座右铭。我只是准确地传达它。我的意思是，Circle 的，你知道的，正如我们所说，它是小火龙。或者不，是喷火龙。它是 C++ 的喷火龙，小火龙。或者不，是喷火龙。它是 C++ 的喷火龙，小火龙。
That sentence did not go great for you. Listen, I got confused because I don't know the Pokemons. I really don't know what I'm going to do if they can't fix these glasses. I'm afraid to tell my girlfriend because she has identified that I am a little bit of a klutz. And she's going to, and I know, I know she's going to make fun of me for this. So I'm just going to be like, hey babe, I just decided to go get new glasses today. No reason at all. Anything else? We got a few minutes left before
那句话你可没说好。听着，我搞混了，因为我不懂宝可梦。如果他们修不好这副眼镜，我真不知道该怎么办了。我有点害怕告诉我的女朋友，因为她已经发现我有点笨手笨脚的了。而且我知道，我知道她会拿这个取笑我。所以我打算直接说：嘿，宝贝，我今天决定去配副新眼镜。毫无理由。还有别的吗？我们还有几分钟时间
we wrap this up. So I'm thinking about doing some interviews at Lambda Days 2023 coming up on June 5th and 6th in Krakow, Poland. We've got Jose Valim who's speaking there, Simon Peyton Jones,
在结束之前。所以我在考虑在 2023 年 6 月 5 日和 6 日在波兰克拉科夫举办的 Lambda Days 2023 上做一些采访。我们有在那里演讲的何塞·瓦利姆（Jose Valim）、西蒙·佩顿·琼斯（Simon Peyton Jones），
and a bunch of other folks that probably have less famous names than them. For those of you that don't know, Simon Peyton Jones is one of the fathers of Haskell. Did you see my tweet? Wrote a... No, I haven't been on Twitter in like probably 24 hours. Dude, go look at my like latest tweet.
以及一堆其他人，他们的名字可能没有那么出名。对于那些不知道的人来说，西蒙·佩顿·琼斯是 Haskell 的之父之一。你看到我的推文了吗？写了一个……没有，我大概 24 小时没上 Twitter 了。老兄，去看看我最新的推文。
It's on topic. Go look at my latest tweet. It's on topic. Go look at my latest tweet. It's on topic. All right. While I'm bringing that up, Jose Valim is the creator of the Elixir language, which is some people will get upset by this, but the most common description of it is Ruby plus Erlang.
这正合题意。去看看我最新的推文。这正合题意。去看看我最新的推文。这正合题意。好吧。趁我把它找出来的时候，何塞·瓦利姆是 Elixir 语言的创造者，有些人可能会为此感到不安，但对它最常见的描述是 Ruby 加 Erlang。
Oh, actually, I did see this. This was from a couple of days ago. And Bryce will put a link actually, I did see this. This was from a couple days ago. And Bryce will put a link in the show notes to this. It is a photo of Bryce with what looks like two ice creams in front of a sign that says Haskell. We love that. Clearly, I didn't love it that much because I didn't heart it or read it. Dude, you're killing my engagement. Should I heart it like, clearly I didn't love it that much cause I didn't heart it or read it. You're killing my engagement.
哦，实际上，我确实看到了。这是几天前发的。布莱斯会放一个链接——实际上，我确实看到了。这是几天前发的。布莱斯会在shownotes里放一个链接。那是布莱斯的一张照片，照片里他在一个写着 Haskell 的牌子前面拿着好像是两个冰淇淋。我们很喜欢那个。很显然我没那么喜欢它，因为我没有点赞也没有阅读。老兄，你在毁我的互动率。我是不是该点个赞——很显然我没那么喜欢它，因为我没有点赞也没有阅读。你在毁我的互动率。
Should I heart it now, folks? I mean, you're listening to this two days later. Yeah. You better heart it. We're gonna, you know,
各位，我现在该点赞吗？我的意思是，你们听到这个时已经是两天后了。是的。你最好点个赞。我们会，你知道的，
go check the show notes, hit the link and see if I hearted it or not. I've got two days to, to make up my decision. And yes. So I'm thinking you're not going to be there for that yeah i'm thinking doing that so i think we're gonna we'll have a couple weeks and then you're also not going to be at c++ italy i was thinking about doing some interviews there as well so then i think maybe
去查看 shownotes，点击链接，看看我到底有没有点赞。我有两天时间来做决定。是的。所以我想你不会去那里的……是的，我有这个打算，所以我想我们会有一两周时间，然后你也不会去 C++ Italy——我也在考虑在那里做一些采访。所以我想也许
the next time we're going to record is when we when we meet up like let's check the schedule actually and we meet up on the 17th so yeah well the next time we record is gonna be live on the road we're not we're not doing it live are we or well yeah i mean i was just typing up the pod but it's definitely not going to be like we could whoa whoa wait wait wait wait wait we could do a live episode no we can't i don't have my actual podcast mike i've got my interview mike anyways it's going to be too complicated to do it live if we want to do something live we can just turn on like i don't know is there a Twitter live or something like that? Twitter spaces, yeah. But yes, if you are, next time we record, not the next episode you hear, but the next time we'll record, we're going to be live. Not live, not live, but together on the road, road trip. And we're probably going to record, I don't know, we'll have to record at least two or three episodes.
我们下次录音将是在我们见面的时候——让我们实际上查一下日程表，我们是在 17 号见面，所以，是的，下次录音将是在路上的现场直播。我们不是在做直播，对吧？或者，是的，我的意思是，我只是在打播客的草稿，但它绝对不会像——我们可以，哇，哇，等等，等等，我们可以做一期直播节目。不，我们不能，我没有真正的播客麦克风，我有我的采访麦克风。不管怎样，做直播太复杂了。如果我们想做点直播，我们可以直接打开——我不知道，有什么 Twitter 直播之类的东西吗？Twitter Spaces，对吧。但是，是的，如果你在——我们下次录音时，不是你听到的下一集，而是我们下次录音时，我们将在路上。不是直播，不是直播，而是一起在路上，公路旅行。我们可能会录制，我不知道，我们至少得录制两到三集。
So you'll have three weeks of content. We're going to record a lot because we're going to be driving a lot this is gonna turn into a philosophy a philosophical podcast and we're gonna we're gonna play we're gonna play road trip games it's gonna be so much fun there's gonna be very limited sleep oh and we we are so the last day uh we're following gasper's itinerary but the last last day... Which I have not looked at. I just let Bryce look at it. This is a mistake because you may have... I've been super busy because I was at KXCon.
所以你们会有三周的内容。我们要录很多，因为我们要开很多车。这会变成一个哲学、哲学播客，我们要玩，我们要玩公路旅行游戏，这会很有趣，睡眠时间会非常有限。哦，我们——所以最后一天，呃，我们按照加斯帕的行程走，但是最后一天……我还没看呢。我只是让布莱斯看了。这是一个错误，因为你可能会……我超级忙，因为我在 KXCon。
I've been super busy. What are you talking about? No, I've been super busy. I was in Montauk. Where were you? I don't even know where I was. Connecticut, New York. KXCon.
我超级忙。你在说什么呢？不，我超级忙。我在蒙托克。你在哪儿？我甚至不知道我在哪儿。康涅狄格，纽约。KXCon。
I know we had a whole episode linking the show notes on ArrayCast, but it was absolutely fire. Best conference I've ever been to. Excuse me. Excuse me. You've been to C++ Now, a conference that I organized, which is the best conference you've ever been to. C++ Now 2019 was, up until KXCon 2023, the best conference I've ever been to. It is now the second best. And, yeah been to. It is now the second best. And, yeah, no, it's still the second best.
我知道我们在 ArrayCast 上有一整期节目并在 shownotes 里放了链接，但它真的是太火爆了。我参加过的最好的会议。打扰一下。打扰一下。你参加过 C++ Now，一个我组织的会议，那才是你参加过的最好的会议。C++ Now 2019 在 KXCon 2023 之前是我参加过的最好的会议。它现在是第二好了。而且，是的……参加过。它现在是第二好了。而且，是的，不，它还是第二好。
I'm sorry, CPP North. CPP North is way up there. But having it hosted in Aspen at that little conference center and also just, like, meeting all these people, like Ben Dean, et cetera, for the first time, it's hard to compete with that. So, yeah, number two now is C++ Now 2019. Number one, KXCon 2023. What can I say?
对不起，CPP North。CPP North 也很棒。但在阿斯彭的那座小会议中心举办，并且第一次见到所有这些人，比如本·迪恩（Ben Dean）等人，这很难被超越。所以，是的，现在排第二的是 C++ Now 2019。排第一的是 KXCon 2023。我能说什么呢？
All right. Well, I got to go get new glasses. All right, folks. If you're in, if you're going to be at Lambda Day, although no one probably that's going to be at Lambda Days actually listens to this podcast yet because they're all academics and functional programmers. And that is not our audience, I don't think. But if you're going to be there at the conference, come say hi.
好吧。好吧，我得去配副新眼镜。好吧，各位。如果你在——如果你要去 Lambda Days，尽管可能没有任何要去 Lambda Days 的人会听这个播客，因为他们都是学者和函数式程序员。我不认为那是我们的受众。但如果你要去参加那个会议，来打个招呼吧。
If you want to be on the pod, I'll have the mic on me at all times or like 80% of the time. And if you're going to be at C++ Italy, I'll also be there. Come say hi. I think it's a free conference. No, I don't think. I think it's a free conference. No, I don't think I know it's a free conference. So if you're in Italy, Rome, Italy, go sign up. I'm not sure if there's a limit to how many people can come, but
如果你想上播客，我随时或者大概 80% 的时间都会带着麦克风。如果你要去 C++ Italy，我也会在那儿。来打个招呼吧。我觉得这是一个免费会议。不，我不觉得。我不觉得，我知道这是一个免费会议。所以如果你在意大利，罗马，去注册吧。我不确定人数有没有限制，但
maybe it's sold out if that's the case. Why is it a free? Anyways. Alright. Okay. It's a free conference because that's the way it is. Alright, folks. Bryce has got to go fix his glasses. Will he get them in time hashtag lens crafters uh you know you're getting a free advertisement here lens crafters so you better deliver all right all right i'll see you later all right well well uh the next time we chat could be in sia or Vienna. But you didn't answer my question whether you can go without lunch
如果满的话可能已经卖完了。为什么是免费的？不管怎样。好吧。好的。这是一个免费会议，因为情况就是这样。好吧，各位。布莱斯得去修他的眼镜了。他能及时拿到吗？#LensCrafters，你知道的，你在这里得到了免费广告，LensCrafters，所以你最好给力点。好吧，好吧，回头见。好吧，呃，我们下次聊天可能是在萨尼亚（Sia）或维也纳。但你还没回答我的问题，你到底能不能不吃午饭，
and whether you can go without a day of exercise. I mean, we can just buy a protein bar and then eat it in the car, correct? Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the topics that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave any thoughts, comments, or questions. Thanks for links to any of the topics that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave any thoughts, comments, or questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及你能不能有一天不锻炼。我的意思是，我们可以买个蛋白棒然后在车里吃，对吧？请务必查看你的播客应用中或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的 shownotes，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何话题的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下任何想法、评论或问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。